[Music]
all right joining me now Senator Eric
Schmidt member of the armed services
committee Senator Ron Johnson a member
of the homeland security committee
Senator Schmidt I know U you're all in
the meeting um with zalinsky today were
any skeptical Minds changed no there was
nothing new here it's the same old same
old and I think what was striking though
is you had the president from Ukraine in
the halls of the capital talking about
the importance of protecting the
sovereignty of his borders and here we
have a president in this country that
refuses to address the sovereignty of
our own border our Southern border where
there are millions of people coming
across terrorists we have no idea who
these people are so there's a total
disconnect and it was it just struck me
the the conversations here in Washington
on this are so different than in real
America Real Americans are struggling
they want us to focus on that not a
blank check for an endless war now
Senator Johnson your colleague Mark
Kelly uh revealed today that there's
really no strategy for Ukraine watch
this what does an obtainable Victory
look like in Ukraine there will be a
clear winner and loser in in this
conflict
I mean everybody needs to understand
that I mean there will be an end to this
and we need to make sure that the
ukrainians win I'm still short on the
specifics of what victory looks like
well let's start with them not
losing uh is this e8th grade well let's
start with them not losing what are the
American people gaining here well first
of all there is no strategy for Ukraine
to win because they can't win uh the
only way they could win is they'd have
to start lobbing missiles into Moscow to
you reduce you know Russia's support for
the war they can't do that the Pentagon
knows this though right the Pentagon
knows that they have lost the war
already this is 22 months they they
tried summer offensive it didn't work
this is a bloody stalemate every day
that goes by more ukrainians die more
Russian conscripts die take no joy in
that more Ukraine gets destroyed so this
war should be brought to an end the
sooner the better uh because every day
the outcome ends up being worse it's
going to have to be negotiated
settlement and from a standpoint of you
know what America wants we want to
secure border and that's what go
separate things I mean of course we want
a secure border this whole idea of tying
them together that was a Fool's errand
from the beginning tying tying our
border to Ukraine what we do to Ukraine
makes zero sense certainly the way that
President Biden wanted to do he just
wanted more money to more efficiently
encounter process and dispers we need to
actually secure the Border yeah but they
have no credibility on that and I think
it's also worth noting we're already $
112 billion into Ukraine they want
another 60 billion in this that's a down
payment another 160 right we've already
heard in other briefings another hundred
billion doll request is coming next year
and I think it's responsible for us to
ask to what end here how does this serve
I mean there's there's no articulation
of strategy what victory means it's it's
sort of insulting now go ahead I was it
was interesting because president zinsky
did say if you know you don't get if he
doesn't get support from America this
will turn into Guerilla War well that's
really what he ought to be telling Putin
so there's no way you're going to be
able to completely take over Ukraine uh
we will fight to the end and this will
be a gorilla war and you're not going to
want that you need to come to the
negotiating table let's end this war now
Fiona Hill who everyone remembers from
impeachment Fame you know she was an
adviser in the Trump White House also
for Obama um she's also on the board of
Harvard during all of this stuff with
Claud and gay she's making the case that
look if America doesn't step up we are
going to have a diminished standing in
the
world Congressman I mean Senator Schmid
excuse me what about that argument that
we have to do this for our standing in
the world I I think the are tial
arguments meant to sort of scare people
into some sort of decision that doesn't
make any sense the truth of the matter
is this is in Europe's backyard and the
European allies need to step up they
refuse to do it we also have legitimate
concerns about corruption that you noted
in your openings and the Democrats have
blocked any movement for an audit really
the IG yeah they don't want to do
Inspector General on this well first of
all let me say that she's a little late
threatening that because we've already
seen a diminished America if you if you
were asked to design a strategy to
destroy the this country you could not
ask for a better game plan than what
President Biden and Democrats does it
seem purposeful to you how could it
almost not be I mean the open borders
the you know 40-year High inflation war
in fossil fuel the embarrassing and
dangerous surrender in Afghanistan which
is emboldened Putin now that's why
Putin's in Ukraine because we
surrendered in Afghanistan he saw the
weakness that's what the MS are seeing
that's what president she sees so
they're destroying this country Democrat
governance is and this cultural Marxism
that you've seen take hold of important
institutions which has played out with
Dei and CRT you wonder why you see these
things happening on the street in
college campuses there's your answer
it's been indoctrination for Generations
we got a woke Pentagon are we're going
to shovel them more money let them
dictate the future they're they're woke
just like this the colleges all right uh
great to see both of you thank you for
coming into studio and love the beard
good on you Merry Christmas hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else